c'était fanny j bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france la lettre des
médecins donc à cette cause cette
pétition de journalistes reporters sans
frontières a été rendue publique hier
que pensez vous de leur démarche et ce
qu'elle peut avoir un impact sur vous
moi ce qui me sidère un peu si vous
voulez c'est qu'il ya des pétitions dans
tous les sens on a vu aussi qu'il ya des
avocats qui se mobilisaient à
l'international on a vu qu'il y avait
ces médecins et on a vu aussi qu'il y
avait des journalistes
c'est à dire qu'en fait toutes les
professions sont en train de se
mobiliser pour dire que ce qu'un assange
est absolument hallucinant dans une
démocratie qui est la grande bretagne et
ce qui est fou c'est qu'en fait ça ne
sert à rien c'est à dire que ces
pétitions qui sont basées à la fois sur
des gens qui sont compétents et
volontaires continuent à montrer que la
torture perdure et que c'est quelque
chose qui est encore pire qu'avant donc
ces pétitions c'est une chose
à côté de ça il ya d'autres
personnalités qui ont contacté la reine
queen elizabeth qui n'est pas rien elle
dit qu'elle ne peut rien faire puisque
c'est un dossier politique
il ya d'autres personnes qui ont
interpellé le premier ministre boris
johnson qui répond écoutez je ne peux
pas me positionner sur un cas individuel
on peut juste faire passer dé loin pour
que les gens soeur dallaire se soient
mieux protégés c'est à dire qu'on tourne
en rond dans une histoire où personne ne
dit d'y être responsable c'est à dire
qu'on dit en gros c'est l'administration
britannique
et puis on peut rien faire alors on peut
peut-être source se demander mais qui
est derrière cette histoire qui quels
sont les noms et des prénoms des gens
qui décident de laisser julian assange
dans cette situation c'est à dire de
violations des droits de l'homme qui
sont ces gens qui sont payés par les
administrations pour que cette torture
continue
justement on parle ici de torture
psychologique on sait qu'il est sorti de
son confinement solitaire puisque julian
assange on le rappelle était privé de
lumière de soins médicaux et donc tout
contact avec le monde extérieur une
situation qui subissait depuis
maintenant plus d'un an est ce que c'est
le terme adapté torture psychologique
écoutez quand on était à l'isolément
dans un âne dans dans une prison de
haute sécurité alors qu'on n'a rien fait
de mal
alors qu'on n'est pas un criminel alors
qu'on est juste un journaliste qui
publie des informations ça pose quand
même c'est un sérieux problème pour les
recommandations des médecins ont elles
été ignoré jusqu'ici puisque il y en a
eu plusieurs justement sur les sur les
conditions de détention de julian
assange
mais il n'y a pas eu que la part des
médecins il ya aussi un expert des
nations unies qui a fait un rapport et
qui donne d'ailleurs des conférences de
presse régulièrement qui explique que
justement c'est un état de tortures donc
quand nous quand nous explique pourquoi
pourquoi ça perdure pourquoi ça continue
et pourquoi justement les personnes qui
sont responsables de ces décisions ne
sont pas inconnus qu'on sache qu'ils
décident de cet état de fait on sait que
l'audience approche on le rappelle le 24
février
il y à cette demande d'extradition aux
états unis et 18 chefs d'inculpation 175
ans de prison c'est un prisonnier
politique on peut dire pas comme les
hôtesses que si jamais les condamner
cela porterait un coup dur au
journalisme et au lanceur d'alert oui
absolument le sujet d'ailleurs de votre
reportage de la conférence de presse
donc vous n'êtes pas c'est un extrait
bien évidemment il est clair que tout
les journalistes à l'international sont
concernés puisque si dieu lune assange
était extradé été condamné aucun
journaliste ne pourrait publier des
informations à l'avenir sur les états
unis ce qui est ce qui est complètement
déments et la phrase d'assange qui est
finalement c'est pas mon cas ce que ce
cas c'est votre quart à vous tous c'est
exactement ça résume très bien la
situation tout le monde est concerné par
le dossier incendie il n'a rien fait
demain à part publier des informations
d'intérêt général ce qui est le métier
d'un journaliste tout le monde devrait
être debout tout le monde devrait être
concerné on peut pas vraiment un appel à
la société à la société à la société
civile de soutenir assange parce que son
cas pourrait être celui de n'importe qui
n'importe qui demain et nous la france
qui avons refusé l'asile en 2013-2014 a
duré neuf ans quand il a demandé sommes
absolument responsable c'est à dire que
l'asile a été refusée pour des motifs
qu'on ignore absolument
mais on pourrait peut-être reprendre nos
lettres de noblesse en extradant d'une
assemblée bien quand même des gens qui
ont été capables de le faire pour carlos
ghosn il ya quelques mois
pourquoi est-ce que la france qui le
pays des droits de l'homme et qui a
accueilli et protégé pendant 25 ans un
dictateur qui s'appelait baby doc
vous savez le dictateur duvalier
pourquoi est ce que les fonctionnaires
ou les agents qui ont été capables
protéger et de s'occuper de ce dossier
l'un ont beaucoup moins de clémence pour
un
un journaliste qui n'a fait que son
travail on peut vraiment appeler la
france à prendre des décisions aussi en
la matière merci beaucoup
stéphanie jivo d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
lanceuse d' alerte
merci merci